malgré tous les efforts la lutte contre
les changements climatiques fait du
surplace l'éléphant dans la pièce si
l'explosion de la population mondiale
la population de la planète est
actuellement de 7 7 milliards
elle passera à 9,7 milliards en 2050 et
à 11,2 milliards à la fin du siècle
la loi est clair qu'une pour une
augmentation de la population barça coin
d'une augmentation des demandes
d'énergie des demandes alimentaire
également c'est certain qu'il va falloir
un jour avoir des discussions sérieuses
au niveau de la population mondiale
les habitants des pays riches ont
évidemment une empreinte carbone
beaucoup plus grande que ceux des pays
pauvres
mais la joue chaque année de centaines
de millions d'humains qui requiert
énergie nourriture et transport avant la
réduction des émissions difficile
l'enjeu de l'augmentation de la
population est préoccupant oui mais le
principal enjeu ce sont les inégalités
parce que à ce qu'on appelle la
transition démographique est entré en
jeu selon ce démographe la croissance
économique qui accompagne souvent la
croissance démographique reste le
principal problème des pays qui devient
économiquement plus viable une
augmentation de la population de la
classe moyenne qui aspirent au même type
de vie que ce que nous avons à
l'incident en amérique lundi sont des
émissions à ce moment à faire capitaine
beaucoup plus faibles qu'en chine
beaucoup plus faible que la moyenne
mondiale mais leur population va croître
beaucoup plus vite que c'est la chine et
la tendance de leurs émissions est
vraiment à la hausse
ça va créer un gros défi pour pour la
planète pour les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il a fallu de 5000 ans
pour que l'humanité atteignent un
premier milliard d'habitants et la peine
du siècle pour passer à 9 milliards
les démographes président que la
population mondiale se stabilisera
autour de 11 milliards avant de
redescendre légèrement le contrôle des
naissances rester la clef ce qui est
déjà acquis dans les pays les plus
riches en éduquant les femmes en les
envoyant à l'école on va leur permettre
de s'émanciper d'un système
ou est ce qui en fait elles sont vouées
à faire de plus en plus d'enfants
même des pays comme le canada qui ont
des taux de fécondité très bas
connaissent une augmentation de leur
population via l'immigration des pays
plus pauvres
ici une chaîne marsolais radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]